dans le bureau de dominique bouvet le
monsieur sport scolaire à l'inspection
d'académie de haute saône
c'est l'effervescence à quelques jours
du début des jeux internationaux de la
jeunesse l'accueil de 300 jeunes qui
viennent du monde entier
ça ne s'improvise pas il ya une
soixantaine de collègues qui bossent pas
jour par jour sur ce dossier il ya plein
de gens en intermédiaire il ya les
collectivités il ya des clubs via l'état
il ya l'éducation nationale c'est
vraiment un énorme dossier parce qu'on
touche à la diplomatie on ne reçoit pas
la jordanie moscou comme on reçoit un
autre établissement classique
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à voir vesoul va accueillir un
événement unique au monde des jeunes des
cinq continents réuni pendant quatre
jours autour du sport de la culture
un temps fort après marseille l'an
dernier singapour il ya deux ans la
jeunesse aura les yeux rivés sur vesoul
et la haute saône
abbas est magnifique en terme d'image ça
montre qu'on est capable de faire de
grandes choses en haute saône et à
vesoul vous savez notre nouveau slogan
c'est vesoul tout d'une grande
et bien franchement je crois que c'est
le cas bien sûr beaucoup de touristes
vont venir
je crois qu'il ya 400 500 jeunes les
accompagnateurs une logistique hors
norme pour un événement d'exception le
camping de vesoul va même être
pratiquement privatisé pour l'occasion
alors l'installation se prépare on
dresse les tentes les chapiteaux pour
accueillir les jeunes
donc là on commence à rapatrier tout le
matériel toute la logistique qui nous
est nécessaire justement le monde est
remonté jeu
moi ça va de l'aude et norvégienne pour
tout ce qu'elle est jeune et le matin
pour garder le lait au chaud les
sonorisations pour sonoriser les
différents sites de pratique des duvets
pour les enfants donc qui viennent on va
dire des p -o parce qu'avec notre climat
est mort un petit peu de mal à
s'acclimater
la cérémonie d'ouverture de ces jeux
internationaux de la jeunesse aura lieu
ici sur la plage de vesoul mardi
prochain à 21 heures 30 avec un
spectacle qui s'annonce exceptionnel